hello and welcome to the new world
review where the villain becomes a nice
guy for a bit and we pontificate on the
stages of development for a human
insectoid hybrid yes that was a lot of
long words because saying the bug is
getting emotional feels a bit less
i don't know deep and i'm nothing if not
as complex as the word pontificate
let's get into it poor violin butterfree
all his greatest fears coming to pass
and he doesn't even know how to deal
with it the softness we saw coming from
meroem
was quite the beautiful thing there's
this harshness and victory in being a
strong man but
that's being counterbalanced so sharply
by behavior he doesn't even know he's
engaging in for the most part the
beautiful moment of softness and the
wonderful confusion in his thoughts
maybe i'm imagining it but the lines
used to draw mary seem to soften and
gain a measure of roundness when he's
engaging with komugi on an emotional
level as compared with when he's away
from her and it's one of those wonderful
things that show us how we're impacted
by those around us that violin
butterfree and mary are both reacting
very
powerfully to the situation whether they
want to or not poor butterboy
is scared that his homeboy is fallen for
a girl
and homeboy king is starting to question
his own existence
it's fascinating that she's injecting
this measure of humanity into him by
continuously forcing him to think
outside the strategic elements of the
game they're playing
because truly this game is being played
on levels now and kamuki is entirely
controlling the board he's been so
strongly shifted out of the realm of
power on it that bringing his power back
to brute strength is critical to him
remembering who he is
or was or what wants to be or wha
that said he made a really important
point there are different forms of power
what he doesn't seem to have realized is
yet is that the ability to engage
empathy
or to shift the emotions of those
significantly stronger than you
is a huge strength in itself emotional
people make mistakes
emotional people get distracted by those
emotions so while komugi is becoming
more strategically minded through her
little bubbles of excitement and
learning
the others are becoming less
strategically minded and more likely to
respond to their emotions than to the
actual situation
at hand i do wonder whether kamuki is
using nen in some way to sap the ability
to think strategically from them or to
heighten emotionality or something
especially as
mary walked into the room entirely
entirely intent on killing her and ended
up saving her from an eagle which
kind of feels like it should be a
reference or a metaphor for something
but maybe not did i miss something the
idea that this eagle was there
proud and beautiful in the previous
scene and ready to just attack to gain
whatever it thought it was gaining
to hurt for the sake of hurting and that
mary then decided to protect her from
that
it sort of makes me think of the old no
one's allowed to hurt you but me
situation that exists between me and my
sibling without even thinking about it
mary destroyed the attacker to protect a
creature he had been
laughing less than a minute before about
being able to destroy without a thought
turns out he needs a thought or maybe
he'd be better off without the thought
that's kind of the point really isn't it
yeah the strength of butterfree's
thoughts and concerns are so incredibly
valid and everything he's seeing is
absolutely correct there are very
significant concerns with someone who
until very recently saw humans as cows
who has now found one that seems
intelligent
is that enough to change his entire
outlook
maybe maybe not what he has realized
though is that king
like cow is a title not a noun it
doesn't have a name
that the others know which means either
they don't see the value in him having a
name
or killing his mother was a bad idea
which you know we'll go with that one
or that he's not a fully functioning
creature because that name was not given
or provided
there's something important about being
given a name or receiving
a name or choosing one will he choose
one himself or will he let komugi decide
he never cared before about whether he
had one there was no need for anyone to
use it because power was all
physical now he's connecting with
someone on an emotional level and he
needs a way to distinguish himself from
the title he holds
it's a huge huge indication of
development but the form of development
is
incredible because it's an indication
that he wants to be more than just the
title
he sees benefit in being able to drop
essentially to kamuki's level
or rise i guess to kamuki's level she's
worthy of his time and attention so she
has been granted
sentient status the three royal guard
have managed to survive his decisions
thus far so they get to have names but
they also get names because to call them
collectively royal guard becomes tedious
and it calls all of them at once which
is you know not helpful
names serve several functions they allow
for communication to become deeper than
the communication he's engaged in now
he knows kamuki well or at least he
knows kamuki better than anyone else he
knows and the fact that he doesn't even
know his own name
says that he knows her probably better
than he knows himself hence the terror
of the current situation
that would be terrifying for most people
he doesn't know himself so how is he
supposed to concretely understand why
he's reacting the way he does
it's quite wonderful when you think
about it he was a premie baby he was a
premature baby
essentially and now he's catching up to
the others in their emotional
development fulfilling basic needs was
the first step as with human babies i
need food how do i get it the next step
was to get a sense of importance in the
world
taking over from the previous leader and
installing himself in a position of
power was sort of like putting a square
block
in a square hole now he's having
existentialist problems so
i guess somehow we've gone from
childhood to adolescence but the effect
is the same
he's having to deal with emotions he's
never had to deal with before and that
he was ill-equipped to deal with because
of how easily he was given everything
else
it's sort of a reproduction of three men
and a little lady except they're not all
men and he's a
super powerful entity but you get my
point meanwhile the other protagonists
are still preparing to break in and do
things as planned
despite not hearing from palm which is
very much a concern and should be a
concern for all of them
all of them they are doing a thing that
seems ill-advised given someone who
who knows the plan and and has powers
that can just watch them i don't know
i look at this ragtag bunch of oddballs
and think well if anyone can do
something about this you probably could
but i feel like
what you could do about it probably
isn't what you're intending to do about
it either way
it makes a good story so let's take a
look at episode 109
109 and mary's asking what do i want to
do with her
what indeed does he want her to be his
queen i think i raised something like
this before
the idea that maybe because he values
the strength of kamuki's strategic mind
he might elevate her but it seemed but
it's starting to seem like something
more
i don't know intense than that and she
seems to care just as much about him
in a way that i'm not sure how to
interpret the interesting thing about
this episode is that i was right in what
i said about the first one
as they all prepare to engage in
possibly the last moment in their lives
each of the characters get some
introspective time and i love that
because it tells us a lot about who they
are
the same as when we lost leol a few
episodes back while the rest of the
characters can spend their time
preparing for combat in the context of
who they are and who they were
and what they've learned about
themselves over this time mary can't do
that because he's in his
existential phase metaphorically it's
great that his introspective moment
happened with him away from the game
table and away from komugi because
it showed us that his desire to know who
he is doesn't come from a need to
dominate anyone
or to control a situation or for some
kind of strategy
it was just a question asked of the
stars at night and who hasn't done that
at some point we all hit a moment where
we question
what or who we are and that's often the
question that comes before
who or what we want to be we can't
become
something unless we know what that
something is and it's such a vast
distance to travel from the vaguely
awful comment about how no one thinks of
giving mercy to cows that happened a
long time ago now
i remember struggling with that phrase
when i heard it because it sounded so
like something someone repeats when they
hear it right i mean it's not wrong
but it sounded so unoriginal a thought
that i wonder whether his composite
creatures had heard it before
one of the things that we still haven't
had confirmed is whether mary is
actually that kid from ages ago or what
the connection there might be
how much of his past life does he
remember given so many ants remember
those things
is he related to komugi in some way that
hasn't been revealed she can't see so
she can't pick any connection between
them visually and he's touched her but
she hasn't touched him which i imagine
in terms of facial shape and such
would be the easiest way for someone
visually impaired to sense a difference
speaking of sensing difference colt is
safe and well and looking after what i
can only assume is the world's first
saiyan while
er it plays with little toys we still
don't really know
anything about that kid but i find it
odd that of all the ants that have grown
up very quickly
we also have a baby that seems to be
growing at the pace of a baby
i'm very confused and wondering how long
that ant was gestated and how or why
that's a thing was it just a creature to
get
cult out of the way is it a
manifestation of his sister i have a
feeling that's not something i'll get
the answer to but
i hope we'll see a full moon and that
kid in frame and and
and we'll wonder all the characters had
their moment of introspection in this
episode and spent time engaging with
their own thoughts i've said before how
much i like this approach to
storytelling and it really doesn't take
much to see all the differences between
them we see nov again who has been
scared pale and thin at this point and
the moment at the end of the first half
where we get to see his eyes with those
deep bags under them the emptiness of
them is a stark contrast to the sort of
neutrality that we saw
before the experience he's had has
changed him forever and yes we knew that
already but we're now seeing what the
other characters have been seeing
nov represents the best or worst case
scenario for them essentially
someone who encountered the royal guard
and will forever have to deal with the
horror but has survived at least like i
say
either the best case or the worst case
scenario and it kind of makes me wonder
briefly whether kiel was had the same
experience and whether his hair and eyes
were originally closer to gonz yeah i
doubt it but it's interesting the more
interesting thing
is the observation that despite seeming
confident coward boy thinks
kilwa looks like he's gonna fade away
the thing about that is
he's also probably right kilwa is
clearly preparing to sacrifice himself
to make sure
gone can get the revenge he wants to get
not considering the idea that if kilwa
himself dies gone will be even
more vengeful gone isn't as consistent
as any of the others in that room so
he's still the weakest link to my
mind and that's very obvious in the way
the others talk about their awareness of
how hard things are going to be
and they're resolved to die for the
cause or awareness that they
likely won't make it out all except you
know
octobuddy um ikalgu ikalgo
who is seeing this whole situation as a
rebirth which is really lovely
we have yet to see what natero's doing
or has been doing this whole time and
i'm holding out for it but i kind of
need him to come back soon because you
know
short attention span if tagashi's trying
to surprise me with a netero return i
need it
soon being 10 minutes out from the
action there's a lot going on and a lot
of threads to hold on to and
speaking of holding onto threads i'll
leave you with this thought the
expectation
that mary would tell pito to protect
kamuhi now exists in the real world
rather than just in my
mind how far is komugi willing to go to
protect the person who's been
nicest to her and would mary use her as
a decoy to get into an
advantageous position i doubt it given
his earnest honor but we don't
know and with those final thoughts
playing in my mind and shared to yours
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
tiptoe through the mental tulips click
here here
and here don't forget to like share and
subscribe
have a great week and i'll see you next
time